[Musique]
il y a un pont là-bas je dormais là-bas
avec ma fille bon di fait que je suis
venu ici ça va ma fille s va à
l'école on se débrouille ici un pe P en
tout cas c'est pas facile la vie d'ici
c'est pas
facile
[Musique]
ou ils ont besoin de bâtiments mais
est-ce qu'ils vont organiser C bâtiment
il vont
organisermp c'est ça le problème si
est-ce qu'on a la les B il vont
organiser Olympi
ici réunion avec
Madame on a cherché pour ici parce qu'il
y a 400 personnes quand
l'étatcide les droits nous sommes allés
où
les gens qui sont venus ici
principalement ils étaient à l'île
Saint-Denis avant l'île Saint-Denis
clairement c'était une expulsion qui
était à enfin c'est le lieu de des Jeux
Olympiques donc clairement c'était ça et
ils ont été relogés entre guillemets oui
en
région et ensuite mis à la rue et du
coup ils sont revenus ici parce qu'en
fait ils connaissent ils connaissent du
monde ici ils ont une communauté ici il
y en a qui travaillent ici
aussi
[Musique]
on a à peu près 400 personnes qui
habitent ici pendant longtemps c'était
200 personnes mais depuis les expulsions
d'autres squats en Île-de-France des
campements enfin la situation est
devenue assez
compliquée beaucoup de gens se sont
retrouvés ici pour pour avoir un toig
sur la tête tout simplement
[Musique]